[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue aux
débrief des questions au gouvernement
le contexte électoral et politique a
plané aujourd'hui sur la séance
l'opposition s'est fait un malin plaisir
d'appuyer là où ça fait mal pour la
majorité
deux jours après sa débâcle aux
élections municipales
exemple avec cette intervention du
député socialiste olivier faur jamais
non jamais un président de la république
n'avait subi un tel revers lors
d'élections municipales
hmm hmm
[Applaudissements]
en réalité les c'est monsieur faure
continuer s'il vous plaît monsieur faure
à la parole
même la qualification opéré au second
tour je veux parler de vos alliances
avec la droite même cela n'a pas permis
d'endiguer la victoire du bloc social et
écologique
alors qu'allez vous faire de cette
défaite je conviens avec vous que cette
élection a été pour la majorité une
déception et nous aurions souhaité faire
davantage bouger les lignes mais votre
perception des élections municipales
passées je vous là vous me laisse assez
songeuse vague verte aux élections
municipales convention citoyenne sur le
climat l'écologie a été le thème phare
de cette séance pas moins de huit
questions ont été posées sur ce sujet
j'en ai choisi une pour vous celle de
marie noëlle battistel skin député
socialiste et elle regrette que
certaines des propositions de la
convention sur le climat est déjà été
portés par des députés socialistes à
l'assemblée mais sans trouver lé moindre
écho ces bonnes poires sont la
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique qui lui a répondu écoutez les
changes
un grand nombre de ces propositions ont
déjà été portées par notre groupe depuis
2010 est grand plan de rénovation
énergétique avec la prime pour le climat
augmentation de la part du bio dans les
restaurants scolaires renégociation des
traités commerciaux reconnaissance du
crime des cosip hadopi 2017 toutes nos
propositions en phase avec les
aspirations des français vous les avez
rejeté je comprends donc qu'il est plus
facile d'accepter de bonnes idées
lorsqu'elles viennent des citoyens que
lorsqu'elle émane de votre opposition au
ministère la transition écologique et
solidaire quand on ouvre les placards il
tombe des centaines voire des milliers
d'idées qui avait été très justement
porté par le gouvernement précédent mais
jamais mise en oeuvre regardez par
exemple fessenheim vous parler d'action
mais qui a décidé de mettre en oeuvre la
convention citoyenne pour le climat sec
président de la république
c'est un pari démocratique fou c'est
aussi les propositions qu'il a reprise
également à l'exception de trois sans
filtre c'est aussi des propositions qui
seront transmises ici voilà et pour
finir cette image les applaudissements
des députés de la majorité au premier
ministre edouard philippe une séquence
tout sauf anecdotique à l'heure des
rumeurs de remaniement clairement les
députés en marche ont semblé apporter
leur soutien à edouard philippe
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
autre débrief des questions au
gouvernement
[Musique]